aeo eo eo eo
oh oh oh oh oh no, there is no war love e Oh
, people say it's old-fashioned, but if
you speak too well to a lot of
things like that, it just seems like your heart stops for a moment
.
2 Hello,
I'm not a singer-songwriter. Uh
[Music] The sound of
footsteps
is not just a song. It's
just a sound.  It could be the sound of a spoon, or it
could be a
bright sound
of
a
hug.  The intestines Halla
and
the wealth that match the beat and the audience
must ride this trinity
There is sweet liquor, but there is drama,
so that’s the
reason for that.  The
fan is
written all
over, and the wind blows softly. If it were a
player like this, the silver wind
would rage. When the
audience gives the New Year's Eve, the sound of Mori
says it all, it looks like a flower, and it looks like March after putting it all together.
Kern we
[music]
oo Ah ah,
if it's a famous singer, just watch this under the old winds In
Myeonyang Hoffman,
it's not important to just go to the bottom
, there's a waterfall
.
When I'm trembling, Kwangwoon light board Some big
waterfall, the ashes of our voices,
orifices, four lanes, and
things like Ori Kwai.
It is great to appear without
You can see it as a clown, and it
was the sincerity of the person who caused it
woo
Then 5 tool
Eyeball Domestic 4
[Music]